تتفاقم الاوضاع على الارض هنا في الاوضاع
الانسانيه اوضاع الحياه بصفه عامه نحن
الان في جنوب الخرطوم في احدى محطات
الوقود متوقفه تماما
الكل هنا في حاله انتظار تشاهدون الاصطفاف
الكبير لهؤلاء المواطنين هنا في هذا
المكان في نجد ان هنالك انتظار يعني
انتظار دون جدوى دون جدوى لعمليه هذه
الوقود وارتفاع اسعار الوقود في مواقع
كثيره خاصه الان يمكننا ان نستمع الى
الاخوه يعني كيف تنظرون الى ازمه الوقود
كيف ماذا يعني انتم تنتظرون الان
هي واقفه
وبالنسبه لتجار السوق الاسود
يعني الليله الناس كلها عايزه تتحرك وما
عارف انها تتحرك كيف يعني الليله دي انا
عشان اقدر لي بنزين
40 الف للجالون الواحد كويس
لانه الناس دي تتحرك فيها يعني عايزين
نوصل رساله لو في جهه مسؤوله لو حكومه لو
اي حاجه
عشره
يعني
ماذا الذي يحدث الان بالنسبه والله نحن
رايحين طبعا اول شيء السلام عليكم
قبل الضرب ذاته فيا يا اخي نحن المواطن
بيعاني والناس نزع حد وما لاقين زاد وكل
يوم بايتين وما لاقين بنزين وما لاقين اكل
ولا لاقين شراب يعني الحاله كلها فوضى في
فوضى
عشان
الحته ما في الا توفير لمياه لاكل شراب
الاسعار غاليه في غلا يعني
40 مليون جالون والناس ما لاقيه يعني انت
يلاحظ العربيات
دي كلها
على اساس انه الناس يطلعوا من البلد دي
وما لاقينا نطلع من البلد دي يعني اغلب
الناس عشان تت تطلع من الخرطوم يعني الناس
جاست تطلع كيف انت اذا كانت بتقول احنا
ندي الناس لاربع خمسه يوم عشان يطلعوا
والناس ما الاقي بنزين يطلعوا شايف انت
الشرائح والحفلات والبكا الوقفه ما لاقيين
عشان يطلعوا كيف يعني هذه واحده او هذا
الجزء من المعاناه التي يتحدث عنها
المواطنون فيما يختص بتوفير الوقود
وانعدام المواد الغذائيه كذلك هنالك مشكله
كبيره في توفر السيوله خاصه وان المصارف
متوقفه التطبيقات البنكيه ما تزال يعني
تعاني نقص كبير
وتعطيل تعطل في هذه الخدمه بالاضافه الى
ان الذين حتى الذين يودون مغادره الخرطوم
ليس بامكانهم ذلك لان الحركه الان وهذه
حركه المغادره اصبحت محفوفه بالمخاطر من
ناحيه امنيه وبالاضافه لانها ايضا ليست
هنالك وسائل اسعار التذاكر ايضا بلغت مبلغ
كبير جدا يعني المسافر الى الى شمال
السودان التذكره ب 150 الف جنيه سوداني
الى مصر ب400 الف جنيه سوداني كما ان
المعلومات التي ترد اليهم من معابر
الحدوديه حدث فيها اختناق كبير دون ان
تكون هنالك اي نوع من الانفراج في هذا